Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at why it
is that witches are so commonly depicted flying
broomsticks.
You may have heard that the reason witches
are commonly depicted flying on broomsticks
is to get high!
But more than just a corny joke, this is essentially
true.
It's thought the idea of witches flying around
on broomsticks came from the practice of concocting
hallucinogens, and then using a broomstick
to administer the drug to certain sensitive
regions, thereby bypassing some of the negative
side effects these hallucinogens cause when
taken orally.
But let’s backup a little.
Until quite recently, rye was the primary
grain from which bread was made.
Susceptible to a disease known as ergot, caused
by the fungus, Claviceps purpurea, rye was
so commonly infected with it that until the
1850s, people thought the purple ergot that
grew on the rye was actually a part of the
plant.
Notably, ergot contains a number of compounds
including some hallucinogens.
Thus, when a supply of rye became contaminated
with ergot, those who consumed it sometimes
also got a strong hit of the LSD-like fungus.
Not everyone who experienced ergot poisoning
minded, and in fact many people, including
women, actively worked with a variety of plants
for the express purpose of inducing hallucinations.
Popular plants experimented on included several
tropane alkaloids like henbane, jimsonweed,
mandrake, and nightshade.
Together, these intrepid researchers discerned
a variety of poisons that, in lesser quantities,
could produce a desirable hallucinogenic effect.
Most of these hallucinogens also produced
unwanted side effects when ingested, including
rash, nausea and vomiting.
Fairly early on, the pioneers of getting high
realized they could bypass this discomfort
by simply absorbing the drug through the skin.
Many well-respected members of society were
investigating the properties of these potions,
including court physician Andres De Laguna,
who in the 16th century studied such a substance
after taking it from the home of a woman accused
of being a witch.
He then tested it on another woman with the
following result: "No sooner did I anoint
her than she opened her eyes wide like a rabbit,
and soon they looked like those of a cooked
hare when she fell into such a profound sleep
that I thought I should never be able to awake
her...
However ... after the lapse of thirty-six
hours, I restored her to her senses and sanity."
He also revealed that the substance was composed
of "soporific herbs such as hemlock, nightshade,
henbane, and mandrake," and that the woman
was not at all pleased about being woken up.
She reportedly said, "Why did you awaken me…
at such an inauspicious moment?
Why I was surrounded by all the delights in
the world."
Laguna then noted that, "From all this we
may infer that all that those wretched witches
do and say is caused by potions and ointments
which so corrupt their memory and imagination
that they create their own woes, for they
firmly believe when awake all that they had
dreamed when asleep."
Yet another account by Giovanni Della Porta
in the 16th century also affirmed that the
application of this witches salve had the
result of a woman he saw use it adamantly
claim that "she had passed over both seas
and mountains."
Back to the absorption method- it was quickly
discerned that two of the most effective places
on the body to rub an ointment for maximum
hallucinogenic effect were the mucus areas
of the genitals and sweat glands of the armpits.
This topical means of drug delivery gave rise
to thicker potions, balms and salves.
For ladies who wished to partake, since brooms
were readily available, it was a no-brainer
to dip a broom handle into the ointment, and
then straddle it.
Contemporary accounts indicate that as the
balm began to have its effect, riding the
broom became even more fun.
For instance, Raphael Holinshed noted concerning
the accused witch, Lady Alice Kyteler, in
1324: "In rifleing the closet of the ladie,
they found a pipe of ointment, wherewith she
greased a staffe, upon which she ambled and
galloped through thick and thin."
In a 15th century account, Jordanes de Bergamo
notes, "But the vulgar believe, and the witches
confess, that on certain days or nights they
anoint a staff and ride on it to the appointed
place or anoint themselves under the arms
and in other hairy places."
Confessed witch Antoine Rose claimed that
it was the Devil who gave her the concoction
and that to use it, she would, "smear the
ointment on the stick, put it between her
legs and say ‘Go, in the name of the Devil…!’"
So how did we get from salve covered broomsticks
to flying around on them?
After all, most of the early artwork depicting
witches and their broomsticks tends to just
show them on the ground and using the broomsticks
(often in the nude) as previously described.
In the 16th century book On Witchcraft, Johann
Weyer noted that once one of these ointments
was applied to the genital area, it produced
"a sensation of rising into the air and flying,"
which caused many to believe this was done
in order to "meet for devil worship...."
About a century earlier, in 1453, the French
male witch Guillaume Edelin confessed to this
practice of flying on broomsticks, including
mentioning watching his "aged mother straddle
a broomstick and whisk up the chimney and
out of the house."
Needless to say, in this instance his aged
mother likely wasn't the only one partaking
in the hallucinogens.
And, as Andres De Laguna noted, people under
the influence of these drugs seemed to firmly
believe what they were seeing in their hallucinations
was real, even after it was all over.
This "rising" effect mirrors the more modern
exploits of Gustav Schenk, who described his
experience with one of the seemingly common
witches flying ointment ingredients, henbane,
in the 1960s: "I experienced an intoxicating
sensation of flying . . . I soared where my
hallucinations . . . were swirling along."
He didn't say how the drug was administered,
or whether or not a broom was involved...